sky news understands that the government
is considering
waiving the requirement for people
who've received
two vaccines the double jabs to
self-isolate if they come into contact
with someone who's tested positive
for covid19 that we can bring in our
political correspondent rob powell he's
in westminster what are you hearing rob
yes this was reported in the times this
morning jonathan but we do understand
that it is true that the government
is considering in the early stages but
it is looking at
potentially getting rid of the
requirement to isolate
for 10 days for those that have have had
two
vaccinations and are fully protected if
they are named as a
close contact of someone that has
covered so at the moment
if you are named as someone that's been
in touch with someone that has tested
positive you're told to stay at home for
10 days and not go out
now that um is early days but the idea
is being discussed
in westminster to get rid of that and to
instead
have to take daily lateral flow rapid
result
tests to make sure that you are negative
and you would only have to isolate if
you got symptoms or if you tested
positive
on one of those tests crucially though
this would be only for people that are
fully protected that have had both doses
of a vaccine there is a trial going on
at the moment of about 40 000 people
um who when they're named if they're
named as a close contact
can take daily tests uh instead of um
isolating i think that the final
decision will depend on what the results
from that trial
um are but obviously the benefits are
that people would be able to
carry on with their life pretty much as
normal as long as they tested negative
they could go to work as normal could go
out and about as normal
as well i expect there may well be some
criticism of this being restricted only
to people that have had
two doses uh what provision will be made
for people that can't have the vaccine
what about people
that for whatever reason don't want to
have the vaccine what about younger
people
who may not get their second dose until
later this year i think
the idea would only be brought in later
this year but will everyone
have had or been offered those two doses
by then
this also builds on some news we were
reporting earlier in the week that
people that have had two doses when
they're coming back from ambulance
countries
uh may not have to quarantine under
plans being discussed in westminster as
well so this idea of
offering more privileges to people that
have had two jabs
it's clearly in the ascendancy in
government
um at the moment i think it will need to
be carefully handled and carefully
discussed though
there will of course be concern as well
about the reliability of those rapid
result natural flow tests as well so
lots to consider
but this is one possible idea being
looked at
you